La distancia que recorre un objeto es
directamente proporcional al tiempo que viaja.
Déjame llamarle a esta distancia "d"
y a este tiempo le vamos a poner "t".
Entonces lo que nos están diciendo es
que existe una constante "k",
de tal forma que "d", la distancia,
es igual a "k",
esa constante multiplicada por, "t".
Muy bien, esto es que "d" sea
directamente proporcional a "t"
y luego nos dicen,
si un asteroide recorre 3000 kilómetros en 6 horas,
¿cuál es la constante de variación?
Bueno, aquí le pusieron constante de variación,
yo le digo la constante de proporcionalidad ¿vale?
Bueno, entonces vamos a meter los datos
que nos dan a esta igualdad,
nos dicen que la distancia que recorrió
fue 3000 kilómetros...
3000 kilómetros,
entonces 3000 kilómetros es igual a esa constante "k"
multiplicado por el tiempo en el cual lo recorrió,
o sea por 6 horas...
horas...
y lo que nos piden es determinar "k",
es decir, necesitamos despejarla de esta ecuación.
Y para hacer esto basta dividir
entre 6 horas de ambos lados,
aquí dividimos entre seis horas,
de este lado dividimos entre 6 horas,
seis horas...
y por lo tanto,
a ver, aquí esto se cancela,
de este lado,
3 mil entre 6 es 500,
500...
y las unidades nos quedan
kilómetros por hora.
Bueno,
déjame reescribir esto por acá a la derecha,
entonces "k", la constante de proporcionalidad,
es igual a 500,
500 kilómetros por hora...
kilómetros por hora...
y entonces listo,
ya tenemos la constante de proporcionalidad,
o bien, como le dicen aquí en el problema,
la constante de variación.